hey everybody it's Charlie we got to
talk about walking dead Thunderdome we
got the greatest of reunions just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet if anything happens to
Carol if she gets a cold we riot so if
you guys are brand new to the channel i
do weekly Walking Dead videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything they're
finally actually doing that the
characters feel like they have active
gold their actions in each of the
episodes are moving them towards that we
have an endpoint we know this war with
the Savior's is coming so now they're
forming alliances everything is
happening all the same time it's so
great so there is a new round of the
walking dead giveaway going on i'll
explain that at the end of the video go
to top 10 WTF in comic-book easter eggs
MVPs of the episode had to be
Thunderdome Rick Gabriel with that mouth
on them in Darrell who track down Carol
for that great reunion in actually
number ten meet the new group this is
not a group from the comics her name is
Jada that's the same name as the white
witch from chronicles of narnia make of
that what you will but it's not the
whispers this is an alpha this is a
magnet group there are a lot of other
groups in the walking dead this is march
to war vol.19 where several volumes
after that in the comics there's so much
comic book material for them to cover
the whispers all those people come way
way later so when we saw these boots we
saw how hardcore they were they had a
female leader like some of the other
groups that we haven't met yet there
were a lot of questions now we know this
is Thunderdome
it's like something out of Mad Max mix
with Lord of the Flies it's so crazy in
that weird formal way she has the
Speaking so i'm really interested in her
character she seems pretty cool guns
give us lots of guns number 9 that
opening standoff with the Savior's this
is all part of the Ezekiel plot him not
wanting to get into the fight
Richard being determined to draw them in
so he has another standoff with that
total prick that takes his gun and
Morgan staff does nice callback for that
at the end of the episode whatever
you're holding onto it ain't there
anymore
the staff itself is sort of a metaphor
for the way he respects life he refuses
to kill it's literally been taken from
him so now he might have a reason to
kill again that doesn't mean that he
will but just like Carol refuses to kill
there might be that one thing the one
friend that gets hurt that pull them
back in so there's anything there
setting up here is
Ezekiel is probably going to get pushed
over the edge of something happens to
Benjamin that will be the thing that
brings them in because Benjamin like he
says is pretty good with the staff he
disarms the situation but he tells them
not to rush into a fight so that sounds
exactly like what Benjamin is going to
do he's going to throw down something
will happen he'll get himself killed and
that will be the tipping point for the
kingdom joining the Alliance but if
they're going to pay off anything they
have to let richard gallagher this
dude's I out he totally deserves it
number eight I hear you're up Bowman
Darrell gets a crossbow back you can
just hear everyone cheering in the
background just the roar of everybody
just getting so excited that he's
raising that up in the air
the only thing that would make that
better is if you were wearing a poncho
when that was happening like here's your
crossbow
here's your poncho now hop on the
motorcycle and let's kick some ass
so number 7 Richards big plans Darrell
gets to see the clubhouse with all the
secret weapons you see this is katie
backpack and it looks like maybe it
belongs to Richards daughter or
something like that
this is that place where we saw him
break down crying Richard one of my new
favorite characters from the kingdom so
far just because he's so crazy he's so
determined to draw the Savior's into a
fight so they can crush them so Darryl
once he slowly starts finding out what's
going on he starts teasing Carol slowly
gets the idea come on tell me what is
her name in Richard finally explains the
WTS plans at number 7 makes Darrell
throw down so he wants to go to savers
into a fight you know we've had this
nice mural here of what's going on in
the episode is actually a truck out of
the Smokey and the Bandit movie but you
see the robber robbing the stagecoach
it's a nice visual metaphor for what
Richard wants to do to the Savior's that
are driving by but also a metaphor for
what the Savior's are doing to everyone
else there the robbers that are taking
from everyone else but even after they
wrestle themselves bloody he still tries
to convince Darrell that this is what
they need to do is going to happen
sooner or later we're going to get
another chance but if you're confused
why Darryl was so upset about Carol it's
because she would have been collateral
damage in this first strike a tent so
that's like heroin on that big care if
she starts sneezing if anything happens
to her I'll kill you
number five hardcore Gabriel at the
stand up so he's like Rick's height man
he just like rick is the person to get
you whatever
you need it's all about stuff the
garbage pail kids are kind of like an
organized more formal version of the
claimers claimed lead claim Gabriel we
played all the stuff from the boat is
essentially a great art for him you get
the big explainer for what happened in
the last episode why he bailed with all
the supplies
he's actually doing a really good thing
if it's really strong heart for his
character i'm really happy with where
they've taken him he's not one of the
biggest turnaround from all the
characters i'm expecting the same thing
for Dwight's character someone who goes
from being human trash to being a really
cool character within the span of a
season so expecting big things for
Gabriel as well as Dwight I know it
always feels like when people like
Gabriel get those really awesome marks
then they pull the rug out from under us
and kill them for Gabriel's not super
high on the list of people that I think
we're gonna die this season I feel like
he's got two strong of an arc inches in
the way that Carol did became this
really amazing character they're going
to want to keep him around for a little
bit longer be on season eight so
anything goes I feel like they could get
to a solid 10 seasons with the comic
book material that they have at the rate
they're blowing through it
CJ's can let me know in the comments so
he just feels like anytime they give the
secondary characters like that are
really amazing art something really bad
is on the horizon so as long as he
doesn't get too full of himself or get
to heroic I feel like he'll be okay but
this is so much fun number for rick has
to enter Thunder dome and defeat the
mouth of Sauron Walker to win them in
alliance with this new group if you
don't know who that is there was this
big deleted scene from The Return of the
King where there was this creature that
was made to look like this Walker who
became a mouthpiece for Sauron to speak
through literally speak through so Rick
wins Thunderdome cut his hand in the
process he better get that cleaned up
pretty fast he hurt his hand more than
anything I feel like that's the hat tip
for what happens to him in the comics
that thing that they're probably never
going to do on the TV show the number
three Rick makes the deal with Jada
there was that funny moment where she
gags that the idea of shaking his bloody
hand is hardcore she is they gave them
so much set up like oh my god it's
another version of Carol the Terminator
that is going to be so much fun to see
her with all the guns they're going to
get for them but they have that funny
haggling scene where they're like okay
we'll give you a third of the stuff we
still she explains the boat we were
waiting for a long time for someone to
go get that stuff we don't do that we
actually just take stuff from people we
don't go out and find stuff ourselves so
she seems weirdly complicated and it's
super interesting i can't wait to see
more character but as much as he seemed
impressed with the idea of Gabriel
speech the way he talked breakup of the
way he proved himself
I think it's just the idea of all the
stuff that they'll get to take from the
Savior's that's the reason they're
joining the Alliance like oh crap we're
going to get a ton of stuff we take down
this other group there's also a big deep
cut for way back in season 3 Michonne's
rainbow cat if you don't remember that
because of that trash cat here this is
replace the one that you lost
I believe that that is an easier way for
the rainbow cat but you guys can let me
know in the comments that was from like
a really young Carl side trip to the
king county cafe where she busts in as
all these walkers in there and she comes
out with this rainbow cat just couldn't
leave this behind just too damn
beautiful number two it is the big hat
tip for oceanside you saw how
conveniently they set that up at the end
of the episode okay we need a lot of
guns
Tara you've been out further than any of
us why don't you tell us where not to go
and she has that funny look on her face
like oh I got I got an idea I know where
to go
there's another group led by a female as
well maybe they'll have something in
common with this other female lead group
so whether or not the actual oceanside
people come to help them out physically
at least get most of the guns that they
need but you can see other setting
things up it's not going to be super
easy like 123 we have all the people all
the guns let's move on now so the other
things they need to pay off from the
terror episode that's really what this
was it was the payoff from the terror
episode is the key card which i think
the biggest theory right now probably
the best theory is that that is how they
opened the doors at the satellite
station so hopefully we'll find out
about that either next week or the week
after because next week seems like a
really saviors heavy episode so we'll
touch base with all the people we
haven't seen since the show's come back
but really like the number-one moment
has to be that Carol Darrell reunion at
the end of the episode so cry worthy
such a great fake-out reveal to where
they come up with the Cobblers they're
like hey you know we just wanted to
check on you they go away knocking at
the door Carol I got dammit people
bothering me in its Darryl they both
break down crying the whole thing here
is just delaying the inevitable Carol
will find out about Abraham and Glenn
event
too late like you saw her like break
down cry if anything happened to them
I don't know what I would do her soul
with diet she would be Terminator Carol
full-on 100% no going back
so the real question out is is she going
to find out from someone else and that's
what's going to bring her into the fight
or is it going to be like the Benjamin
think where this innocent person that
she kind of cares about a little bit
that Ezekiel really cares about might
end up dying in that brings them in
either way we have a really great
reunion moment just letting us know that
Carol will eventually come back but it's
going to take some big WTF moment before
she does either she's going to find out
about her friend or a new friend is
going to have to die so let me know in
the comments which you think it's going
to be what's going to happen tomorrow
that have some new spider-man homecoming
suppose there's some more Marvel and DC
but there is a new round of the walking
dead give away all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner blake johnson please private
message me on the back into my channel
so i can get your contact details while
you wait for that you can click here for
brand new game of thrones and you can
click here for all my Walking Dead
videos thank you so much for watching
everyone let's high-five i'll see you in
the next video